was it like working on the remake of the
longest yard with adam sandler you have
any funny adam sandler stories adam's
got a whole beautiful group that he
works with and it's all in his world and
his guys and and wonderful people i kind
of was a little unsure of the whole
journey
um until the day that's you know because
i just you know i just trying to do
something with the character and i think
everybody wanted it to be a little more
middle of the road and and i got that
that's you know that's their choice
their movie and the whole thing the best
day that i had on all of the longest
shirt and i had a lot of good days come
on i'm playing a football player i'm a
football fan it was just a lot of fun
i did walk up when when the camera was
rolling and you had these like 300 pound
guys in front of you you know when when
the stunt quarterback was not in going
literally walking down the line to like
romanowski and goldberg and going hey
hey screen actors guilt s-a-g not nfl
i'm in i'm in the game now